hello everyone welcome back to the
collateral interviews youtube channel
for another exclusive interview
and i'm very excited about you guys know
this already i can't get enough beer
straighten right now
i've got fear street simon on the
channel fred heschinger
congratulations like i don't i don't
have words to say this
anymore i'm so obsessed with this series
i'm so happy for you guys
congratulations thank you uh that makes
me very happy
and i love that you're obsessed with it
thank you before i get to fear street i
did want to go back to the beginning a
little just so everyone can get to know
you a little
more and one of my favorite movies of
2018
eighth grade and your scene in it is
quite memorable so looking back on
filming that
is there anything about what beau did to
you know
create a good environment on set or a
way of working with you as an actor's
director
that makes you think like that was such
a great thing to have is one of my first
big features
the whole yes the whole thing i mean one
thing that was
sort of simple thing or not simple but
like it never happened before or after
and it was really special to me was like
i i have a small part of that movie and
yet um
when i got cast he let me read
um with other people who hadn't been
cast yet
and in that we got to improvise and play
and sort of find the character
it was also really illuminating as an
actor because it
you know i had auditioned for all this
time and
and and always sort of thought like if i
didn't get something out like something
was wrong with me
and being able to for him to sort of
open the curtain and show that other
side of the process
was this incredible thing where like
just read with all these
unbelievably amazing actors um
and and they were all completely
qualified and talented and it was just
this thing of like
finding the right mixture so it wasn't
it just took an
it made it less moving on then i felt
less
personal about um a lot of it and that
was nice and then i don't know he's just
he's i i will say like i've he
it's one of that's one of my favorite
scripts i'd ever read and and
since then and now and what surprised me
was still
how um free he was with it like like i
just want to do it
word perfect because i thought it was
word perfect and still beau is very
like just let everyone play at the same
time like even though he was a writer
director
when he stepped on set as a director he
kind of
became something else as well so it's
just this cool
thing to see like how someone can build
that entire
thing and i i don't know just like
there's so many lessons it was also just
how you treat people and and and make
sure that people feel comfortable
and open and know each other and all
that kind of stuff that again makes it
so that like
you can i just think we do our best i
think people do their best work when
they feel
safe and comfortable that's when we can
take risks and he definitely made
me feel like i could go for it i am a
very big believer
in that as well speaking of which so
another
movie that you are excellent in is news
of the world and i swear like
what was it last year early last year
i'm busy watching that movie and your
sequences come up and i'm like hmm like
like he's really good he's something
special i'm gonna see more of him and
sure enough now this year i get two
things that you're in that i'm also
obsessed with
so speaking of setting the right tone on
set you're busy working opposite like
one of the biggest of the big actors in
tom hanks
what is something he did as a number one
on the call sheet and a major leader
in this industry on that set that makes
you think when i'm gonna lead my
you know major hollywood motion picture
i want to do that too
he saw like that every person on set
made the thing what it is and and
that meant that um he spent time
talking to everybody and getting to know
everybody again that that sort of thing
of like
you know maybe setting up a shot
tom would be talking like would be
talking to everyone who's involved you
know background artists and
and and production crew and just
everyone was kind of it was a combined
thing and like
like i think again there's this there is
this thing that's not it's not true
that's like like you can think that like
if you just like sanction off yourself
and you like protect yourself you do the
most true work and
in reality and watching him it really
was the opposite it was
like we have to open ourselves up to
each other and that
that's not an impediment to to to doing
honest
and sometimes very dramatic and
and even dark work like like it even if
anything it makes it easier because
people trust one another and and i don't
know i just it was also like
it's like it's as much your acting is
the fun part like acting is
is you know you get to act like that's
the joyous thing like
that means that the rest of the work is
sort of as an actor
that's number one on the call sheet is
is is making sure that
everyone else is comfortable that's and
that's also fun in its own way but
but that like is is equally important
when you're at the top i think is
is just you know making sure that i
don't know the thing the ship is moving
and
everyone's on board and and um there was
also a thing with
greengrass too which was we were really
able to take our time
and that's somewhat rare um
um and uh uh it was really really
special like
we would play with scenes inside and out
until we felt that they were right and
it was
really inspiring to be on a set and and
feel like that's what's important we can
put the priority
on our um on that feeling on that that
feeling of being like
right in the moment and trying to get
that feeling right rather than just
hurrying all the time and getting the
day i greengrass is
really brilliant at like
at letting the scene exist and trying
you know throwing out the end of it and
changing the order and seeing what
that's like
like just kind of the weird lab
scientist beauty of like
how how can we get how can we get this
scene to sing
and it was just really it was really
wild i remember very well that
we did a scene one time and um
we like he you know classically like
keep moving in moving in
we started in and then we moved and then
we thought we had it and he moved out
but when we were like far wide of us on
the wagon
we improvised a slightly different thing
because we just kept playing
and greengrass decided to move back in
because he heard a few little lines that
he hadn't heard before
that he was like oh no let's try that
too and i was just like oh my gosh
that's so liberating and thrilling and
exciting to be able to like
to be like oh wait no like he was
listening he was always listening
um and i just thought that was it was it
felt i felt very honored to
to be with all of them and be a part of
that it was so cool
i could ask a million more questions
about news of the world but
i'm obsessed with fear street so i have
to ask a million questions about that
right now instead beginning with the
fact that
simon to me feels so incredibly specific
to you so what is the
very first description of that character
you got like the the day one what did
that character look like so i'm so
curious to know how that changed when
you stepped into the role
i don't remember the exact breakdown of
the initial script
um but i do remember that that
in in one of the original scripts there
was
um like a comment on a perfume that he
smelled like that he used like a cheap
perfume that he used
and it was a specific brand and the day
that i had my
my um audition with lee like the
like i sent a tape and then it was an
in-person audition with lee
i'm not very superstitious but i but i
but i i really really
really wanted this role and i felt the
real love of
what lee had written with phil and and
so i went to the um duane reed on the
corner
and i thought they had the little hey
the thing where like
they lost i don't know they can pharmacy
sometimes where they lock up
perfume for some reason i like i don't
know why it's
the same price as the other things i
don't i don't know if they were like
these great perfume robberies but
anyways it was locked up and i remember
like
asking a guy like could you would you i
never did that before like may you
unlock this glass case so i can buy this
thing and like
i was almost going to be late because it
took away like 10 minutes it took a
while for me to get there and finally
got it
and i like lathered myself with this
thing very superstitiously
um and yet i found it some i don't know
i found it helpful somehow
um but the other simon was always there
on the script but it was also
a testament to to leave because i mean
she
she really and he she really cares about
the people in her movies and
i i if you're a fan i think like i hope
feel this thing which is like
they're the gnarliest you know glorious
most unflinchingly horror movies ever
and at the same time
they have this like huge beating heart
underneath them and i think that comes
from
her care and her interest in character
and so i remember when we before we
started filming
we sat and we talked for like two hours
about simon and his life
and our ideas and there were many things
that are in the movie that i think were
unsaid
by us that we both cared about but there
were also many things that we shared
that were fleshed out and
it was just it's just this feeling when
you and i've i've been lucky like every
director i've worked with
thank god has had this i think this is
what what's made
me feel so honored to work with them
which is like this this sort of
love for character this love for people
the people who actually exist in the
frame
um um and and lee just has that and
that's i think what makes every
character
in in this trilogy so specific and felt
you feel it while you're watching it and
that's a big part of the reason why i
think fear street isn't just like
a fleeting fun thrill for us to have now
that's that's a big part of the reason
why i think it's an
all-time long lasting uh trilogy we've
got here
i was also wondering did lee give you
any specific
character references when playing simon
because i had a whole conversation with
someone who tried to convince me that
you've got some major stew from scream
vibes and like
i can kind of see it but but stu is a
bad guy
i'm pushing back on it a little bit yeah
thank you we didn't we didn't talk
i mean i rewatched scream and watched
all those wonderful
90s horror films um there was no
character reference but there was a lot
of um
there was a lot of just movie sharing
back and forth sort of
what about this what about this in terms
of kind of feeling um
um there are a lot of there were a bunch
of 90s gems
that um i hadn't seen that
lee put me on to that were really really
fun to watch in the lead up
what was the best of the bunch i've
never seen go before
oh wow i haven't thought about that
movie in forever
really interesting yeah it's just a
really interesting reference and really
really fun it's funny with inspirations
it's like
i always have a couple things i'm
carrying from movies that i love
but in it's an
it's it's such it's so it's like it
really is a
um it's never it it's kind of like
you just it's nice to get inspired by
something but i always know that like
whatever the inspiration going into it
whether it's a real person
or it's some form of research or it's a
movie or a character in a movie
it always kind of it's just the thing
that leads you to set
and then it kind of fades away and you
have to you have to kind of let that
preparation
fade and become part of the movie so so
like even the stuff that i love to watch
that i was kind of like my calling card
to rev me up
that stuff always be that always goes i
always sort of forget it once the thing
has been made
um in a way that's why simon feels
purely you like i said before
thank you what was it like
making the transition from 94 to 1666
did did lee ever have any conversations
with you as far as
how much of simon should come through in
that other character
we i felt that that stuff was so like
wonderfully in the script that there was
this thing where the the characters are
different in 1666
but there is there are shared
sensibilities and there's also this
shared struggle for the town of
shadyside that is you know
people who have been pushed to the side
outcasts and
misfits and um the characters who in any
other movie
would die in the first 10 minutes are
actually the
the the heart and the essence of this
film um
this whole trilogy and and so yeah there
was there was kind of like shared ideas
and thoughts but
but there wasn't anything it wasn't like
like i do think of him as different but
i do think
you know the way i think about it it's
like they're different people but i
think like if isaac and simon met
they get along like they'd have a good
time together
i think that's sort of the third thing
yeah same with
with kate and lizzy you know it's like
they're different
but but they're sometimes after similar
things and they would understand one
another
100 i would very much buy that just for
fun
if you had a face off against one single
shady
killer one on one which one of the bunch
would you pick and why
just talking about them sometimes gives
me the chills really barker that image
of billy barker gives me
is gives me the most creeps and i would
want to fight him i think i'd quickly
probably lose but i would still
i would still pick him yeah billy barker
i've been busy changing my answer like
every other day i'm like trying to find
a loophole
the last one i said was uh was the
pastor
but i think i'm only saying that because
we only see the aftermath of what he's
done
so i think in my brain i'm i'm thinking
i could run away from him
but i probably can't i mean that's risky
you
you're you're asking to get your eyes
gouged out that's pretty good
i feel like any of them are risky just
in general do you think you could
survive a horror movie like are you uh
are you are you the person that would
that would be in the house with a
slasher and
run up the stairs and be doomed or would
you be you know
the last one standing um
no i i i would i mean i'm just petrified
i would
i get scared of such minor things in
life i can't imagine
like knowing that there's a killer like
across the door no i would
i would i would i would totally fold
under that pressure for sure
what are the others have the others said
that they'd be the last what did kiana
say
i i did some uh i did some cast
superlatives with kiana and
one of the questions was some was
something along the lines of
you know like which cast member would be
most likely to trip and fall while
they're running away from a serial
killer
i'm incredibly i'm incredibly clumsy
i think she gave you that one and also
who would be most likely to drop
something
on their wardrobe while at craft
services
i had a day where i so i can spoil stuff
right
yeah go crazy so like in the you know in
the third one where we
come back at the end with he's uh where
um
good is haunted by the kind of like gory
visions of all the people that he killed
right and they they put all these
prosthetics on me and
it was like a it was a weird mixture of
like a lot of prosthetics and blood
and scars and also this bald cap so i
looked like
i looked like an old man and like i had
like
like sideburns that were all red and
bloody anyways i was just like covered
in all this
stuff and yet they had nachos
for for lunch that day and so it was
this like i couldn't
i was like you just covered it there's a
picture of me where i'm like covered in
blood
and i'm eating the nachos and they're
all combining
to make this very weird uh
this very weird cauldron of um different
pastes and whatnot
and uh yeah i would i would i'm so messy
i'm a
very messy eater i'm a very clumsy
person
i would fall on i would definitely fall
down i would definitely
fall into food i i kian is totally right
all right here's a here's a fear street
theory question for you
who do you think takes the book in the
end
oh that's a great question i'm not even
going to touch that one
[Music]
i could tell you what she threw out
there which which i think is a
fair theory that's that's floating
around and does does have some like real
substance to it
she suggested a ziggy
which i can say i i can i don't want
that to happen because i
like the feeling of closure that we get
for that character but at the same time
kiana did point out that there's certain
nuances in gillian's performance that
could maybe support that yeah yeah
that's great
i mean yeah that's great i i think there
are a couple options
um yeah you dodging it you you can't
well no keanu really want keanu wrote in
the group chat the other day like
but seriously guys who grabbed that book
and there was
no one touched it it was radio silence
everyone was like
too controversial i'm not i'm not
stepping in there
it's fair is fair i'm impatient because
i love this series but i
i love it i love your ideas i think if
we're all together at a table
we could like argue all day about who it
is i think it's very exciting there's a
lot of there's a lot of possibilities
i could go on and on all right white
lotus now
so this is going to be hard because i've
watched the whole thing so i'm tempted
to dig into all of it but i'm going to
try to keep this to episodes one and two
so
first actually like a somewhat silly
question are you
actually like listening to watching or
playing anything on the multitude
of screens that he has that is a work
it's a working nintendo switch
yes i i um i hadn't
played nintendo in like an incredibly
long time i used to
in middle school every day we would play
super smash bros
and get a big thing of um uh fruit punch
and we'd like share it for a week like
if we buy fruit punch for the week
basically
and we do the same thing every day and
we play this game but i hadn't played it
in like i don't know six years or
something
and so getting it again on the switch
was it was kind of fun to
to step back in the old game but yeah uh
so it is working but
um it's it's it's it's hard to focus on
video games when you're
working with steve zahn i mean you just
sort of want to take all that in rather
than
better than the screen it's so good your
back and forths are really just like
like
spot on it's such a like it's such a
specific like style and tone and
cadence also and i imagine some of that
can only come together in
post-production with the score and the
edit but
what can mike white do for you as an
actress director on set
in order for you to like you know play
the scene truly
but also kind of like tap into the
satire of it all
mike is this incredible um
combination as a writer and as a person
as a director on set
um which is that he he sort of is like
unflinching in terms of the cringe of it
right like
he will twist the knife to the furthest
degree like he's just like
he's like ready to see okay most people
would cut there but like what happens
after
and what happens after that what happens
after that because like in life we do
not have the convenience
of edits you know so often i'm in the
middle of an interaction i'm just like
oh no what did i do and you can't you
can't go to the next scene you have to
stay
in it and endure whatever is happening
or however you
made this person uncomfortable or or you
feel uncomfortable or whatever it is and
i just think he's really unflinching
with the cringe of it
but he's also really tuned in to the
the um the kind of
um he has a lot of compassion
for for the characters and i so i think
that yields
a certain empathy as a director to also
um see the story through their eyes so
like
um for instance that that scene in the
second episode
um i remember a really wonderful note
or not even note but like a wonderful
thing that we were talking about before
we did the scene
was how like in mark's eyes
when i agree to go scuba diving that's
like
the end of the movie that's like where
the camera pulls back and it's this like
victorious moment you know um and so and
again like that's
i feel like mike was able to see each of
the characters story through their eyes
and then when you watch it hope i mean
the way that i feel when i watch the
show is i just relate
to everyone and and and um
in the times that i like it and the
times that i don't i mean in the times
that i want to relate to them the times
that i'm a little embarrassed that i
relate to them but but i do
every single character and i think i
think that comes with that
that combination which is like you you
can't sugarcoat it
but you also still have to have love and
as a director
he is that i think about those
in-between moments
all the time i think about what happens
after after a movie or show
also with characters because it's not
like they walk off sunset they have a
life
and other challenges after but i also
think a lot about here
oh before yeah yeah i think about that
too and
in particular with quinn what is his
life like before getting to white lotus
is it as simple as like he is at home
with his family with his head buried in
the screens
and if that is the case does he do that
because
the screens are so accessible to him or
is it more so
because the people around him push him
into the screens
yeah that's a great i you know i again
like i have my thoughts on everything
but i also
i feel that once it exists i don't want
to say too much in terms of that stuff
but
but i'm with you like i really i the
stuff that i really love like
you get you get to know characters and
through something and
and you do they do sort of stick around
in your head and i
i feel that a lot like there there are
there are a lot of movies where i
i don't know for years after you sort of
remember characters as if they're people
that you know and that
that that is something that i really i
really love and
and i hope i hope can keep it so that's
cool
that's awesome if you don't have to run
off i'm asking you one more fear street
question i was reading that you and
olivia have a little uh movie trivia
thing going on like what what kind of
movie trivia are we talking about are
you asked
is it like have you ever played the
movie game
what i played variations of the movie
you're clearly puff but like i'm sure
you played many movie games but what
um a game where you say um
an actor and then you say a movie that
they're in and then you say
another actors in that movie they say
another movie that that act has been in
you play okay so and then you challenge
and then you try and stump each other
and you challenge each other
so yeah we we um we played that you know
six months straight on set
and i will say it got heated sometimes
i mean we had we had a couple car rides
where
it was it's really fun to go at it i
learned that game in camp
like when i was in middle school and
it's um um
it was really fun to find someone who
was
um that eager to play it and that
usually i try and play it and people are
like
okay i'm bored now and olivia was like
we just it was so fun we just went at it
i've played that version of it and also
my family is obsessed with what we call
the
we call it the movie linking game where
you just name two
actors and you need to figure out like a
way to craft a path from one to the
other it's like this person was in this
movie with this
and then you link it to the other person
i'll run this game by olivia and we'll
try and play it if
um yes yes sharing it i'm curious who
would who would come out on top in that
game
all right like i'll let you go now fred
huge congratulations
to everybody out there fear street
trilogy if you're here you've already
seen the whole thing but watch it again
on netflix and also
sunday nights hbo it's where you can
watch the white lotus and
it is excellent fred congratulations
thank you perry it's nice to meet you
thanks for
um thanks for watching everything and
thank you for your questions